[Musique]
allo ici police secours ne quittez pas
en recherche votre correspondant merci
hello polissonne de faune holden ou et
looking for you correspondent mieux à
qui la police et à pau death hablar
connard ntem et arts inc communautaire
gracia pronto police coup aspect
t'appelle favori se nomme charles kely
votre correspondant ce soir en raison de
la grève qui affecte une certaine
catégorie de notre personnel nous ne
sommes pas en mesure de vous présenter
le journal des sourds et malentendants
rassurez vous vous retrouverez cette
rubrique la semaine prochaine et votre
fils il lui arrive d'être ambidextre
aussi oui et vous avez réagi comment à
ce moment là comme vous êtes aperçu
qu'il était ambidextre les petits ça
vous a fait du chagrin
bien sûr pourquoi jamais envie d'aix je
ne tiens pas être je suis indépendant a
vu leur ai dit que celui qu'on appelle
optimiste et ambidextre aussi donc en
même temps si longtemps j'ai envie votre
mari n'ait pas lieu je suis sûr qu il
ait pas envie de vous non plus l'employé
plus les mots de la langue française
n'importe comment c'est important vous
savez ambidextre
que veut dire ambidextre ambidextre veut
dire qui peut se servir de la main
gauche comme de la main droite
un exemple messieurs vous a senti un
petit peu obsolète quand même nom
tantinet hoya défaut que j'aime pas mon
challenge pourrait très vite obsolète si
on
même monsieur a dépassé ou vous a dit
vaut mieux que tous sont obsolètes et
vous voit vous êtes comment obsolète non
au nom je suis présentement à la barasse
à l'usiné péchiney mais non mais non
rien de tout cela
obsolète venir démodé dépasser horde
usage
un exemple messieurs
[Musique]
vincent si j'adore la nouvelle petite
peugeot allait aller faute est une
peugeot sa fait une opel que tarte à la
mouche pour roussey oui la bei
mouss tpiy méfiez-vous des imitations il
ya vous savez en ce moment en
recrudescence de faux garçons de café
nous avons un truc pour vous permettre
de distinguer les faux garçons de café
des vrais garçons de café regardez vous
prenez une bouteille vide vous appelez
le garçon garçon ait voulu lancer la
bouteille vide
vous l'avez constaté ce garçon esquiver
la bouteille c'est donc un faux garçons
de café la réaction maintenant d'un vrai
garçon de café lorsque vous lui lancez
la bouteille voilà ce qui doit se passer
[Musique]
voila l'exemple type ce garçon de café
n'écoutant que sa conscience
professionnelle a rattrapé la bouteille
vide
c'est donc un vrai garçon de café faites
comme nous le test du garçon de café ça
et efficace
paris tout est magie la la la la la
[Musique]
à
on imagine des magies
un merlin chanteur quel joli match en
terre gelée rouler une pelle lui faire
un bisou
bonjour mais là le chanteur tu étais
bebook oui la terrible je présente mon
fidèle assistant avant ce soir
zizou l'assistante merlin l'enchanteur
zizou
quand je lis ou je vais faire un bisou
bonjour aussi sous la dig
oui tu la princesse qui embrasse oui là
des mimiques oui ok le plaisir de
rencontrer une âme charitable pour te
récompenser jeu mais de changer ta
petite combine ça si ça change médias
pro celle là abracadabra corneau occulte
poum poum tchak
monsieur tomber dans la formule la
recommencer sous cornes de bouc
préservatif en bois poum poum tchak
qualité déjà la formule préservatif en
bois le préservatif à boire
ah oui c'est comme ça je suis la pitié
salut les cartes vermeil vous avez pas
vu par hasard
najim hook mois promise 4 le prince le
bonnet ou arrangé les choses
le prince le juge à les retrouver je la
tiens jacques un préservatif endroit
corps n'occulte boum tchak au manager
nos fatwas ma beauté
bonsoir c'est l'heure du journal des
sourds et des malentendants des
expériences en laboratoire ont montré
que certains bryozoaires réagissent
talent attaques de mollusques prédateurs
du groupe né des nudibranches sorte de
limaces de mer en secret tend rapidement
des épines défensive les parties de la
colonie défendu par ses épines ne sont
alors plus attaquées par les mollusques
il se pourrait que de telles réactions
induite par consommation qui n'avait
auparavant pouvait que chez quelques
plantes ou invertébrés primitif soit
assez répandue chez les organismes
coloniaux exposés à des rencontres non
fatal avec les prédateurs décidément les
grenouilles d'australie n'ont décidément
pas
après la baisse à une abrutie saoudite
et par là la mia maï liste est avant
tout connu ici que ma connaissance de
margueritte radio fasse équivoque et les
[ __ ] et galure ségur franchement
est ce que j'ai une tête de phénomène
socioculturel
bonjour monsieur je vois là oui mais il
paraît qu'on peut tout dire avec les
fleurs s'allumant messieurs les
florentais langage universel alors vous
allez me faire un bouquet qui va dire à
ma femme que ce soit nous serons trois
parce que j'ai invité georges à manger
alors qu'elle fasse du poulet mais
qu'elle n'oublie pas d'être deux fois
sur terre mentionne numéro 3 voilà donc
vous m'avez déjà alors ces trois hilare
il vous faut un liseron de personnages
et une pipe à mosta 3 thermostat transit
pour pourtant j'avais compris bien que
deux jeux excusez moi non alors ces
trois personnages trois personnages
voilà donc trois villages dans sa chair
ça va nous faire le prix d'un bouquet
alors puisqu'on peut tout dire avec les
fleurs j'en profite et j'ai un patron et
j'ai droit à une augmentation de 12 me
pour cent mais indexé sur le coût de la
vie mais ce qu'on peut y faire un
bouquet qui dira mon patron
si ça ne m'embête pas de régulariser
seul mois hanche à nous et nuit pour
cent avec ses trois chardons de
clématites aucune gentiane voilà je
crois que vous allez pouvoir le passer
ce cas d'excès oui monsieur
trop cher même si ça vous faire le prix
d'un bouquet d'un message à l'origine
pour le premier bouquet vous avez des
amis terme le numéro 3 parce qu'elles se
trompent prêt à recompter mission oui
j'ai bien les thermostats numéro 3 j'ai
bien mis le poulet g 2008 en main et les
deux bouquets ou ensemble ça va pas le
faire trop trop ça veut faire le prix de
bouquets ensemble me suis avec les
messages le patron voulu avait du sang
je lui ai absolument tout dire votre
patron jeu de tête sans être un message
aux ennemis % avec ces surcoûts de la
vie monsieur c'est un petit plaisir
vente partout voilà je vous offre ce
petit bouquet de renault et je vous
ajoute en même temps le livre des
langues et des salades venant des
chaussettes offert par la maison je vous
en prie au revoir monsieur
ah ben voilà une qui connaît son métier
alors 3 renoncules tire-toi de rose de
rose pauvres à mieux aux autistes par et
tire toi pour vous tard et à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
serait-ce là moi je le connais il a
toujours raison
jeu de course le plus grand supporter
cela collait au tout pas cherché à
comprendre la soul a tout les atouts
l'honneur de l'impression ce mâtin temps
mais je suis quand même gagné
je crois que tout est dit ou bien dream
city
faut que tu les paies
[Musique]
j'ai bien compris
si un jour tu veux lui parler il est
branché sur la politique économique john
marston est pas ou bien l'on change de
trottoir
et bien compris cela
c'est la star m6
[Musique]
pour tubes écrits
j'ai bien compris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faire moi c'est trois fois mieux vous
avez l'heure s'il vous plaît à la lier à
charge
i'm so why merde j'ai trop tard merci
vous êtes un cadre fatigué excédé par la
vie urbaine et vous avez sûrement
entendu parler des caisson d'isolation
sensorielle désormais de pau a mis en
place dès caisson d'isolation à la
disposition de tout le monde pour une
somme modique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci de pau
[Musique]
l'artiste cowboys
pour toutes écrit
[Musique]